First of all,
obviously when you're going to cut
costs,
start with data,
which businesses are underperforming,
which product lines are underperforming,
which people are underperforming and you
know,
start there.
Uh,
what I think often happens is the
company's hope for some natural process
of attrition,
things start to get difficult.
They kind of take across the board cuts
and that's almost never a good idea.
I remember,
uh,
just recently I was having a
conversation with a cfo in a large
company and they had just kind of had
kind of a blanket policy that every
division,
every a national organization was going
to have to take down head count by 10%.
And I said,
like,
this is across the board.
No exceptions,
no exceptions.
Everybody has to do it.
It's a mandate.
I said,
well,
surely that can't be a the right way to
do it.
I said,
uh,
you know,
you have divisions that have great
growth prospects.
You have others that have gone fat and
Lazy,
uh,
why,
you know,
why just do it across the board?
And he said,
because it's fair.
I said,
how is that fair?
I mean,
you know,
some,
some businesses are already lean,
so is it,
how can that possibly be fair?
He thought him and he said,
yeah,
you're right.
But it's easy.
Well,
easy is usually not a good criteria for
making a business decision.
So the,
the,
the starting approach for any kind of
smart cost cutting is really a very,
very careful analysis of what's grown
fat,
what's going lazy,
where do we have great prospects,
where do we don't?
But costs cutting should never be
uniform.
And across the board,
number one.
Number two I think is smart costs
cutting.
You spend a lot of time talking to
people about what's happening.
You know,
clearly some people are going to have to
go.
And how do you avoid demoralizing all
the folks that are left?
Well,
first you have to be honest about what's
changing in the environment.
That's not too hard at the moment.
Most people get that we're in a very,
very deep recession.
But you also have to be kind of have a
due process and make sure that in the
heat of trying to uh,
bring your costs back in line,
you're not indiscriminate and how you
let people go,
that you're taking people one at a time,
you're really evaluating their
contribution.
They understand why it's they,
that person and not the person next door
to them that is being asked to leave.
And when you have to cut deep enough so
you feel that you're cutting,
you know,
not,
not kind of the slack,
not the beat team,
but you're cutting people out of the
team.
You also want to,
if you possibly can,
let people know that you're going to be
rehiring,
that you're going to want to reengage
them,
but do the whole process in a way where
you not destroyed their loyalty,
their emotional connection to the firm.
That means explaining why it's
happening.
Being sure that,
that they understand why it's,
you know,
why certain people,
not other people.
And if you can,
giving them at least the hope that
there's a rehire when the economy starts
to tick up.
Do all of those things.
And I think you can get through a lot of
the costs cutting without an undermining
of the morale your company or without
finding that doof kind of cut off some
of the most valuable people that you've
eaten the seed card as it were
inadvertently in the midst of a crisis.
So I think you have to be very,
very careful in the way you do this and
you have to recognize that recessions
are temporary.
We've come out of everyone,
uh,
you know,
during our lifetimes we're going to come
out of this one.
And what do you often find is that the
companies that had to cut less deeply
that we're able to,
to kind of soldier through,
did not lose key resource is the not,
you know,
uh,
bring their key capital projects to
halt.
Those are the companies that gain market
share on the upturn.
Cause you know what,
it is really hard to rehire.
Lease great people,
talented people.
It takes a long time to find that or
bring them back on board again.
Make them productive.
It takes time to get those capital
projects underway again.
So if you can find ways of cutting less
deeply through the depths of the
recession,
you absolutely have an advantage coming
out of the recession.
Now it's also true that you know,
some companies over higher,
and I think this is usually kind of a
political thing.
You know,
in most organizations we measure
people's authority and kind of their
status by the size of their budget and
the size of their headcount.
So there's kind of an imperial listing
that people have.
They want bigger teams,
more people and so on.
And so you have to keep that in check.
You know,
you,
you have to keep constant attention on
to all of those key productivity
measures and make sure that at no point
as you grow to those things get
significantly out of whack.
Yes.
You know,
if you're in a fast growing market,
your fast growing company,
you have to hire a bit above,
uh,
you know,
the,
uh,
the demand curve because it takes a
while to bring people on board and get
them up to speed.
But you want to watch those ratios very,
very carefully.
Make sure that they never get out of
line,
that that,
that you at at every moment through the
down and the up curve that,
that,
that you are paying attention there.
If you stop paying attention for a
moment is very easily for people at all
levels of the organizations to pad their
teams with more people to hire a bit
indiscriminately.
And then you suddenly find out that,
uh,
when times are tough again,
you have a lot of slack and you're going
to have to put the organization to a lot
of trauma to get rid of that.
So be careful when you hire right?
Don't over hire,
but also be careful not to over cut
cause coming out of the recession.
The ones that have been able to maintain
kind of the,
the,
the employment status,
the capital programs,
they're going to be the quickest to ramp
up growth and grab the market as it
emerges as we come out of there.